Republicans plan to force candidates who
want to debate in the 2024 primary to
sign a loyalty pledge clearly here
geared at getting Donald Trump to say he
will support whoever the eventual
nominee is going to be and this is the
latest in an ill-conceived and
potentially completely self-destructive
idea from the Republican National
Committee I will explain why let's talk
about these loyalty pledges the
Associated Press reports Republican
primary candidates will be blocked from
the debate stage this summer
if they do not sign a pledge to support
the gop's ultimate Presidential nominee
according to draft language set to be
adopted when the RNC meets next week the
proposal sets up a potential clash with
former president Trump who has raised
the possibility of leaving the
Republican party and launching an
independent candidacy if he doesn't win
the nomination while RNC officials and
Trump aides downplay that possibility
such a move could destroy the Republican
party's White House aspirations in 2024
and raise existential questions about
the party's future
this is so potentially disastrous for
the Republican party and I love it now
interestingly a senior Trump aide could
not say whether Trump would sign the
pledge to support the eventual nominee
but suggested privately that he plans to
participate in the debates campaign
spokesman Stephen Chung declined to
answer the question directly as well
Chung said president Trump is the
Undisputed leader of the Republican
party and will be the nominee there is
nobody who can outmatch president
Trump's energy or the enthusiasm he
received from Americans of all
backgrounds so listen
um I don't think Trump can do this I
don't think Trump can sign that loyalty
pledge and there's a couple different
reasons why
first of all existentially
uh Trump may not win the nomination we
just don't know yet if you put him head
to head up against DeSantis it's not
that good if you put him in a multi-way
race he has a plurality but that could
change and what if he gets indicted or
whatever the case may be there's all
these different scenarios so Trump in
order to maintain leverage and power
really can't sign this pledge because he
kneecaps his own power part of the power
of trump right now
is that if he chooses to go and run
third party
he ends Republican chances in 2024. the
math of it is relatively simple we've
talked about it before you think about
all of these states which are swing
States or their Republican states by but
only by a few points if you take a state
that Republicans usually win by three
Trump saying I'm running third party
if he pulls even just 10 or 12 percent
of the vote in those States
it'll mostly come off of the Republican
nominee and the Democrat ends up winning
Trump running third party is a gift to
Democrats if it happens I would love to
see it he would he would have the chance
at being one of the most successful
third party candidates in history I mean
in the modern era
um you've got Ross Perot is the one that
mostly comes to mind
um Trump would really have a shot at
being one of the more successful third
party candidates in the modern era and
it would destroy Republicans possibility
of winning so that would be absolutely
fantastic but there's another sort of
aspect to this
which is
much of Trump's campaign
like in 2016 is going to be based on
attacking his fellow Republicans and
making fun of them and talking about how
terrible they are and all these
different things
how can Trump seriously attack Ron
DeSantis in the way he's been attacking
him
if he has also signed on to support
DeSantis no matter what if DeSantis is
the nominee it fundamentally doesn't
work and so the Loyalty pledge actually
risks pushing Trump towards that third
party run in the following way if
Republicans if the Republican Party
really holds firm and says Trump if you
don't sign this thing you can't debate
by the way not allowing a former
president to debate would be
unbelievable and many people are writing
to me saying David they would just
Buckle they would just say oh no no
you're allowed to debate but imagine
that the Republican Party says you've
got to sign this loyalty pledge in order
to debate Trump doesn't sign it they say
we're not letting you debate
that pushes Trump to go and say you
won't let me debate I'm no longer
running in your primary I'm now running
third party that's it Democrat wins in
2024. so Trump really does have a very
powerful tool in his pocket and he can
use it like a kajal he genuinely can
it'll be fascinating to see if it
happens